if i could have your attention again
everybody's got to stop stop talking i'm
reclaiming my time
i hope you enjoyed your dinner you're
not allowed to speak anymore
the purpose of our annual gathering is
to note one of the most remarkable
events
in world history the signing of the
united states constitution
and so the establishment of government
by reflection and choice forming a more
perfect union
to secure the blessings of liberty
unlike any other academic institution
hillsdale college celebrates the
constitution teaches the constitution
and upholds the constitution day in and
day out
year in and year out and we have done so
since 1844.
like the um like the country we pursue
the stated
object of our founders the diffusion of
sound learning
for the perpetuation of civil and
religious liberty and intelligent piety
in the land
hillso the first american college to
private in its charter any
discrimination
based on race religion or sex
it was an early force for the abolition
of slavery and we proudly hosted the
great frederick douglass on our campus
it was a second college in the nation to
grant four-year liberal arts degrees to
women
as a non-sectarian christian institution
it maintains by precept and example
the immemorial teachings and practices
of the christian faith
the college continues to uphold the
principles of the constitution
by defending its independence refusing
to count
our students by race and refusing to
bring
one penny of taxpayer money to the
college
and every year you might have heard
every year through
four wars two pandemics and even a great
fire
we have held graduation and we did so
this year
most important the college teaches the
liberal arts and trains students in the
arts of liberty
elizabeth and i are proud parents of a
freshman at hillsdale college
and she is currently taking the core
course required of each and every
hillsdale student
in the united states constitution
her favorite electric favorite elective
i might uh add by the way
is introduction to shotgun
where she was very happy to tell us she
is currently beating
all the boys in the competition
hillsdale continues to carry out its
original mission today
both in the classroom nationwide through
its outreach programs around the country
24 charter schools and counting its
online courses which have been taken by
over 2 million people
in primus which regularly goes out to
over 5 million readers
and by estimation each month the college
reaches over 20 million people through
its various
forms of communication
let me introduce the man who is
responsible for leading this race
institution
i have had the privilege of knowing him
and working with him for over 25 years
we first met when he was president of
the claremont institute in california
originally from arkansas he received his
m.a and phd
in government from the claremont
graduate school
he worked in england as research
director for sir martin gilbert the
official biographer
of sir winston churchill
while studying at the london school of
economics and it was there that he met
his wonderful wife penny who was here
this evening
thank you penny
he was the founding chairman of the
california civil rights initiative which
prohibited racial
preferences in state hiring contracting
and college admissions
he's on the board of the directors of
the heritage foundation the
intercollegiate studies institute
the claremont institute and his past
president of the philadelphia society
in 2015 he received the bradley prize
from the lyndon harry bradley foundation
he's the author of three books liberty
and learning the evolution of american
education
the founder's key the divine and natural
connection between the declaration of
const
and the constitution and what we risk by
losing it
and churchill's trial winston churchill
and the salvation of free government
he is also the editor of the churchill
documents part of the official biography
of winston churchill
begun in 1962 by randolph churchill
and now published by hillsdale college
that project was recently completed
under dr arn's direction
with its 23rd volume
great accomplishment
in addition to being a professor of
politics and history and teaching a
range of courses from aristotle to
churchill
he's the 12th president of hillsdale
college dr larry pjorn
good evening
oh there's a lot of us here is that
legal
sometimes my confidence is shaken that
i'm mature enough
to be president of hillsdale college
even after 20 years
but then i see matthew and he's just
like a kid to me
and you know he's doing okay i mean i'm
amazed
and pleased thank you matthew
we had a board of trustees meeting today
and uh
it looks like i'm going to be employed
for another year
and you know in the middle of all this
mess it's a sign of the times
college has done pretty well i mean you
know really well
but this year was well just passed the
best
financially and in admissions and
because we got disrupted for two months
and we missed each other
now it's just as happy as it can
possibly be
and i learned a lot you know because
when when march
came and all of a sudden for the first
time in 175 years we are disrupted from
having college
it's like combat because now you
have to not only manage a college you
have to fight to be able to do it
and uh because we are unable
at least in the media to count the cost
of the shutdowns as opposed to the death
rate from the
virus which is significant
nobody counts you know the business is
closed
nobody counts what it means for somebody
21 years old
to reach the moment of completion of
their undergraduate
education which is the time when they
finish
preparation to be a fine human being and
not to get to finish that
and we know from the classics that the
completion of a thing
is the fullness of a thing
and we sent them all home so we were
determined to have commencement
and you know
say i was threatened with arrest and
and the people you know implying they
didn't make the threat but implying
those threats
they were astonished that that didn't
finish it
and there was a conversation between an
authority in michigan and our general
counsel
and he said the general counsel bob
norton he said
you know there would need to be a law
right just what you like and don't like
that's not what it's about
what's the law and the law does say
it's not really a law by the way the
governor of michigan with her staff
and i don't know how you guys work but i
can talk to about 10 or 12 people a day
meaningfully so it's got to be she and
10 or 12 people
wrote a thousand pages of rules
in michigan there is a time it's eased
up now
you could buy a garden hoe that was
legal
but it was illegal to buy seeds
and so all the stores that sell the hose
and the seeds
they roped off the seed part which by
the way
served to concentrate people in the
store
genius um
to you many great old friends of the
college i want to thank you for being
here and i want to register in public
that
i'm sick to death of being told that my
daughter kathleen o'toole
is more capable than i
i've known him for a long time and yet
she is great with child and i am going
to ruin
her child i'm going to be the worst
grandfather in history
public notice served
the rule of law is a concept that is
delicate
and essential it is delicate
because it requires an act of obedience
from everyone
including especially people who are good
at power
it's something to which we must bow
we must not think of our station our
strength
our wealth we must think of the law
law is very complicated it's hard to
think of that now
it's essential because justice depends
on it
without it justice is nothing but the
interest of the powerful
without it we will have gone the way
that
thirsemic has proposed in plato's
republic in book one
justice is just what the powerful say it
is
we worry about justice today because
look at the energy
that's put on the left into the reform
of the electoral system
to adjust the results so that they will
always go their way
the rules of the game which are old
older by the way ours is the longest
surviving written constitution
and although we're a relatively new
country relative to many
we are also the oldest country on earth
indeed the oldest country on the history
of earth
and those rules that have kept us
together and kept us free for so long
they mean nothing now
how would we get that back
what kind of people would be necessary
to give it back
we have an example tonight
our speaker tonight is practiced and
skilled
in his trade one of the most
he's already been attorney general once
before
he's done asking about his career he
liked being general counsel for a big
corporation
and i didn't say it but i'll say it to
him now i have my first general counsel
at hillsdale college now
and those guys are unruly he must have
had a lot of fun
he went to columbia and he went to law
school at
george washington he's a native of new
york
he's been married for 73 years no he's
been married
he's been married for 47 years
i've been married for 73 years
although my wife is only 32.
those are qualifications what are the
qualities
i'm just going to cite two by reading
something he wrote
two things he wrote they're very
beautiful by the way
at notre dame october 2019
the founding generation were christians
they believe that the judeo-christian
moral system corresponds to the true
nature of man
do you see what kind of claim that is by
the way
revelation and reason tell us the same
thing he's saying
those moral precepts start with the two
great commandments
to love god with your whole heart soul
and mind and to love thy neighbor as
thyself
but they also include the guidance of
natural law
a real a real transcendent
moral order
the eternal law is impressed upon and
reflected in
all created things from the nature of
things
we can through reason experience discern
standards of right and wrong that exist
independently of the human will
now i will tell you those
three paragraphs encapsulate what i've
been studying all my life
and do you see what they did they give
you because you know our speaker tonight
is very good at power
he's had a lot of it he's not afraid to
use it
and yet he thinks that even while he
uses it
he must obey and that's a commandment
from god
the second thing is about honor i will
tell you that i'm thrilled when i read
this
in may 2019 he was interviewed by jan
crawford of cbs news
and i just was stunned when i heard it
because here's what what she's doing and
what he does she says
when you came into this job attorney
general in the trump administration
you were u.s attorney in connecticut
you had a good reputation on the right
and on the left
you were a man with a good reputation
you are not someone who as you know
accused of protecting the president
enabling the president
lying to congress did you expect that
now that part i think by the way that's
a woman
appealing to a man that she thought was
one of
her kind and you can't be
what you seem to be
he replies attorney general barr well in
a way i did expect it you did
yeah because i realized we live in a
crazy hyperpartisan period of time
and i knew that it would only be a
matter of time if i was behaving
responsibly
and calling them as i see them that i
would be attacked because
nowadays people don't care about the
merits and the substance
that point by the way is like the voice
of doom talking
to live in a world where people don't
care about that is to live in a world of
enemies
to agree with that he says is
antithetical to the way the department
runs
and any attorney general is going to end
up losing a lot of political capital
if he does right
one of the reasons i ultimately was
persuaded that i should take it on
is because i think at my stage of life
it really doesn't make any difference
you're at the end of career she says
i'm at the end of my career
does it mean she says by the way it's
very the things she says are very
sympathetic right
also kind of unbelieving
does it mean that the reputation you
have worked your whole life through
is sacrificed and he says
yeah but everyone dies
and i am not you know i don't believe in
the homeric idea that you know
immortality comes by you know
having odes sung about you over the
centuries
now that last thing that's paradoxical
because like achilles chose
early death and honor over life with his
family
but we learned in the socratic writings
that that's not the highest kind of
honor
the highest kind of honor is to do
right till the last day
and prepare to meet your maker
if we're to get back the rule of law
it will be people like attorney general
william barr
who get it back for us
thank you
thank you very much i'm
very honored to have been invited to
speak
at this dinner and i really appreciate
your
comments larry great to get to know you
i've been reading you over the years and
it's a
it's a real delight to have spent the
evening with you
and uh i'm very pleased to be able to
speak to you uh at this hillsdale
college celebration of our
magnificent constitution and
and i'm a great admirer of hillsdale
as i was telling larry i don't get to
make
many speeches like this i'm usually
talking about crime rates and
that kind of thing but uh
i wanted to speak at hillsdale because
it's one of the few
maybe a handful of institutions of
higher learning where it
uh is actually worthwhile spending the
money to get an education at
and i mean that sincerely
sadly many colleges these days don't
even
teach the constitution much less
celebrate it
you know one out of every four americans
don't know who we fought the revolution
against
it's pretty pathetic and that number is
increasing steadily as our educational
institutions fail us
but at hill hillsdale you recognize that
the principles of the founding are as
relevant
today and as important today as ever and
vital indeed today to
the survival of our
great experiment here freedom
and i appreciate your observance and all
you do
for civic education and education period
in this country now when many people
think of the virtues of our constitution
first mentioned the bill of rights of
course
that's the talking point of the
constitution there's a bill of rights
you have rights
and i guess that makes sense they get
the great guarantees of the bill of
rights freedom of speech
freedom of religion especially the right
to
keep and bear arms just to name a few
are critical safeguards to our liberty
but as president reagan used to remind
people the soviet union
had a constitution and even included
some of these
lofty sounding rights
ultimately however those promises are
just empty words
because there was no rule of law
in that society to enforce them the rule
of law
is the linchpin of american freedom
and the critical guarantee of the rule
of law
comes from the constitution's structure
of separation of powers
now there are many elements of the rule
of law
and there are many many safeguards built
into our great constitution but tonight
i want to talk about
the separation of powers the free the
framers recognize that by
dividing the legislative executive and
judicial powers
each significant but each limited
they would minimize the risk of any form
of tyranny
that is the real genius of the
constitution and it ultimately
is more important to securing liberty
than the bill of rights after all the
bill of rights is a set of amendments
to the original constitution and i know
you all know
that the framers did not think it was
needed
uh they didn't need to con
to include into the constitution and
express enumeration of rights
today i want to talk about the power
that the constitution
allocates to the executive branch
particularly in the area of criminal
justice
the supreme court has correctly held
that under
article two of the constitution the
executive
has virtually unchecked discretion to
decide whether to prosecute
individuals for suspected crimes we all
know that
as the executive vested with the
responsibility for
seeing that the laws are faithfully
executed
the power to execute and enforce law is
an executive function altogether
and that means discretion is vested in
the executive to determine
when to exercise the prosecutorial power
the only significant limitation on that
discretion comes from
other provisions of the constitution for
example
the united states attorney could not
decide to prosecute
only people of a particular race or a
particular religion
but aside from that limitation which
thankfully uh remains only a
hypothetical in our country
the executive has broad discretion to
decide whether to bring
criminal prosecutions in particular
cases
the key question then is how the
executive should exercise
its prosecutorial discretion
80 years ago this spring one of my
predecessors in this job
then attorney general robert jackson
gave a
famous speech to the conference of
united states attorneys in which he
described the proper role
and qualities of federal prosecutors
justice jackson was one of only a
handful i think
three maybe attorneys general who
ultimately ended up
as a justice on the supreme court
much has changed in in the eight decades
since
justice jackson's remarks but he was a
man of uncommon wisdom
and it is appropriate to consider his
views today and
and how they apply in our modern era
federal prosecutors possess tremendous
power power that is necessary to enforce
our laws and punish wrongdoing but power
that like all power any other power
carries inherent potential for abuse
justice jackson recognized this and as
he put it the prosecutor has more
control
over the life liberty and reputation
than any other person in america
prosecutors have the power to
investigate people
to interview their friends and they can
do so
on the basis of mere suspicion of
wrongdoing
people facing federal investigations
incur
ruinous legal costs and often see their
lives reduced to rubble
before a charge is even filed
justice jackson was not exaggerating
when he said
while the prosecutor at his best is one
of the most
beneficent forces in our society when he
acts from malice or
other base motives he is one of the
worst
think about the power of a prosecutor
doesn't they have to answer
to anything outside the office of the
prosecutor
and he can destroy people's lives just
by bringing an investigation
destroy their reputation destroy their
livelihood
in today's world and it's not just
individuals think of the corporations
anderson the accounting firm
thousands and thousands and thousands of
jobs
done away within an instant because of a
prosecutorial decision
and a decision that was largely
discretionary
because individuals are initially
responsible for the crime
and the question of whether or not
you're going to impute that to the
corporation and take down the
corporation as well is largely a
discretionary call by
prosecutors and in today's world
going after a corporation or a
white-collar
defendant is like shooting fish in a
barrel
there is no contest you
threaten a company with criminal
liability and
all the collateral effects that that has
no corporation is going to go to trial
and fight that and the prosecutors know
that's just the question of how much the
check is going to be
and that's all within the control of a
prosecutor
the power as justice jackson said
to strike its citizens not the the power
that the prosecutor has is not merely
it can strike its citizens not with just
the
individual strength but with all the
force of the government
itself and that has to be carefully
calibrated
and carefully supervised because left
unchecked it has the power to inflict
far more harm than it prevents
the most basic check on prosecutorial
power
is political accountability
it is counterintuitive to say that as we
rightly strive to maintain an
apolitical system of criminal justice
but political accountability politics
is what ultimately ensures our system
does its work fairly and with proper
recognition
of the many interests and values at
stake
government power completely divorced
from political accountability is tyranny
now justice jackson understood this and
as he explained
presidential appointment and senate
confirmation of the united states
attorneys and the senior
department of justice officials is what
legitimizes
their exercises of sovereign power
you are required to win
an expression of confidence in your
character by both the legislative and
the executive branches of the government
before assuming the responsibilities of
a federal prosecutor
yet in the decades since justice
jackson's remarks
it's become a commonplace to argue that
prosecutorial decisions are legitimate
only when they are made
by the lowest level line prosecutors the
career prosecutors
handling any given case ironically
some of those same critics see no
problem in campaigning for highly
political
elected district attorneys to remake
state and local prosecutorial offices in
their preferred progressive
image which often involves overriding
the considered judgment of the career
prosecutors and police officers but
aside from that hypocrisy
the notion that line prosecutors
should make the final decisions within
the department of justice
is completely wrong and it is
antithetical to the
basic values that undergirds our entire
system
the justice department is not a
praetorian guard that watches over a
society impervious
to the ebbs and flows of politics it is
an agency within the executive branch of
a democratic republic
a form of government where the power of
the state is ultimately reposed in the
people
acting through their elected president
and their elected representatives
i know i don't include many applause
lines in my prepared speeches
had i known this was going to be a far
side chat i would have cut this shorter
but i will give you some something to
clap that later okay
the men and women who have ultimate
authority in the justice department
are thus the ones on whom
our elected officials have conferred
that responsibility
presidential appointment and senate
confirmation
that blessing by the two political
branches of government
gives these officials democratic
legitimacy
that career officials do not possess
the same process that produces these
officials
also holds them accountable the elected
president can
fire senior department of justice
officials at will
and the elected congress can summon them
to explain their decisions to the
people's representatives
and to the public and because these
officials have the imprimatur of both
the president
and congress they also have the stature
to resist
these political pressures when necessary
and they can take the heat
for what the department of justice does
or doesn't do
line prosecutors by contrast are
generally part of the permanent
bureaucracy
they do not have the political
legitimacy to to be the public face for
tough decisions and they lack
the political buy-in necessary to
publicly defend those decisions
nor can the public and its
representatives hold civil servants
accountable
in the same way as appointed officials
indeed the public's only tool
to hold the government accountable in is
an election
and the bureaucracy is neither elected
nor easily replaced by those who are
moreover because these officials are
installed by the democratic process
that is the appointees they are the most
equipped
to make the judgment calls concerning
how
we should wield our prosecutorial power
as justice scalia observed and perhaps
his most admired
judicial opinion is dissent in morrison
versus olson
almost all investigative and
prosecutorial decisions including the
ultimate decision
whether after a technical violation of
the law has been found
prosecution is warranted
in involved the balancing of innumerable
legal and practical considerations
and those considerations do not need to
be need
do not i do need to be balanced
in each and every case as justice scalia
also pointed out
it is nice to say fiat justice
let justice be done though the heavens
may fall
but it doesn't comport with reality
it would do far more harm than good to
abandon all perspective
and proportion in an attempt to ensure
that every technical violation of
criminal law by every person is tracked
down
investigated and prosecuted to the nth
degree
our system works best when leavened by
judgment
discretion proportionality and
consideration of alternative
sanctions all the things that
supervisors
provide cases must be supervised by
someone who does not have a narrow focus
but who is broad gauged and pursuing a
general agenda
and that person need not be a prosecutor
but someone who can balance the
importance of vigorous prosecution
with other competing values
in short the attorney general senior doj
officials and u.s attorneys
are indeed political but they are
political in a good
and necessary sense
indeed aside from the importance of not
fully decoupling law enforcement
from the constraining and moderating
forces of politics
devolving all authority down to the most
junior officials
does not even make sense as amazing a
matter of basic management
name one successful organization or
institution where the lowest level
employees decisions are deemed
sacrosanct
they aren't there aren't any letting the
most junior members set the agenda might
be a good philosophy for a montessori
preschool but it is no way to run
a federal agency good leaders
at the department of justice as any
organizations
need to trust and support their
subordinates but that does not mean
blindly
deferring to whatever those subordinates
want to do
one of the more annoying things
that i hear and face and you know this
has been going on for decades this
this strange idea that
political officials interfere
in investigations or in cases
and i'm saying what do you mean by
interfere
under the law all prosecutorial power is
vested in the attorney general
and these people are
agents of the attorney general
and as i said fbi agents whose agent do
you think you
are i don't say this in a pompous way
but that that is the chain of authority
and legitimacy
in the department of justice and i say
well what exactly am i interfering with
when you boil it right down it's the
will
of the most junior member of the
organization who has some idea that he
wants to do something and what makes
that
sacrosanct what makes the judgment
of the next layer up or the next layer
up or the next layer up
each layer by the way fanning out and
having broader and broader experience
much more experience and a broader
portfolio and a broader perspective what
makes
the lion attorney who's handling a
particular case their judgment so
sacrosanct
now the idea is i guess well they're not
political and therefore their judgments
won't be political
but for many my experience in the
department
in two different eras
career employees are not apolitical
necessarily some are
some are very political and can check
their politics at the door
and others can't and other and and can
be partisan but
they're not apolitical necessarily
they're human beings like everybody else
and they're very
usually less experienced individuals
than their supervisors
so this is what presidents the congress
and the public expect
when someone go when something goes
wrong in the department of justice
the buck has to stop somewhere and
that's at the top
the statute i referenced was 28 usc
section 509
which couldn't be planar all functions
of other offices of the department of
justice
and all functions of agencies and
employees of the department of justice
are vested in the attorney general
and because the attorney general's
ultimately politically accountable for
every decision
that the department makes i
and my predecessors have had an
obligation to ensure
that we make the correct decision
the attorney general the assistant
attorneys general the u.s attorneys are
not
figureheads we're supervisors
our job is to supervise and anything
less is an abdication
active engagement in our cases by senior
officials is also
essential to the rule of law
the essence of the rule of law is that
whatever rule you apply in one case must
be the same rule you would apply
in a similar case treating each person
equally before the law
includes how the department enforces the
law
we should not prosecute someone for wire
fraud
in manhattan using a legal theory we
would not equally pursue
in madison or in montgomery
or allow prosecutors in one division to
bring
charges using a theory that a group of
prosecutors in another division down the
hall
would not deploy against someone who's
engaged in indistinguishable conduct
we must strive for consistency and that
is yet another reason why centralized
senior leadership exists to harmonize
the disparate views
of our many prosecutors in a consistent
policy
for the department i was
being interviewed by a member of the
press it was a radio interview
uh and i got one of these questions like
uh
well you know why are you you know
interfering in some case over here or
some case over there and i said well why
do you think we have one attorney
general
i said we have 93 districts 50 states 93
districts
why don't you think each u.s attorney
should be a law unto themselves why do
you think we have
one attorney general for uniformity
of law for having consistency
in the application of law for having
someone who has the entire perspective
of the playing field and the cameramen
were all nodding their head this made
sense this made sense
jackson said we must proceed in all
districts with that uniformity of policy
which is necessary to the prestige of
federal law but i think
there's more involved than prestige
uniformity is
what protects us at the end of the day
our system is really the crystal the the
crystallization of the golden rule in a
political system
and that's ultimately what protects us
which is
i'm not willing to do to somebody else
what i'm not willing to have done to me
that is ultimately the foundation
of our freedom okay
so
we see that in the legislative branch
think about it constitutionally here
since i'm talking about the constitution
tonight
the legislature in the united states our
national federal legislature can't make
one law that applies to new york and
another to california
now there are a lot of reasons for that
think about it
because then you could have little
factions in the country you know buying
favor
and building a majority to adopt rules
that don't apply to everyone the same
but it's also because you can't have you
know the rest of the country say okay
we're going to go to war and by the way
the draft law only applies to new york
okay the constitution requires a
uniformity across the nation so that's
legislative when you make a rule
legislatively
it has to apply to everybody
but it also applies in the enforcement
of law
the same uniformity is required
because that is the ultimate grantor of
freedom
all the supervision in the world won't
be enough though without a strong
culture
across the department of fairness and
commitment to even-handed justice
so that's what justice jackson described
as the spirit of fair play and decency
that should animate the federal
prosecutor
sounds quaint today doesn't it in this
in his memorable turn of phrase
even when the government technically
loses its case
it has really won if justice has been
done
we want our prosecutors to be aggressive
and tenacious in their pursuit of
justice
but we also want to ensure that justice
is
ultimately administered dispassionately
so one thing i'll say is that the job of
the prosecutor
is to try the case and
attempt to achieve a conviction of guilt
but that's when the job of the
prosecutor is over
in some cases we may express our views
as to what the sentence
should be but the sentencing belongs to
the judge the judicial function
and that after the prosecutor wins the
case
we like that competitiveness we like
that spirit and aggressiveness but
once the case is won passions must cool
and justice in the sentencing phase
has to be fair and that's why the
sentence
is given by the neutral
judge now we're all human
and like any person a prosecutor can
become overly invested in a particular
goal
prosecutors who devote months and years
of their lives to investigating a
particular target
may become deeply invested in their case
and assured of the rightness of their
cause
when a prosecutor when a prosecution
becomes
my prosecution particularly if the
investigation is highly public
or has been acrimonious or if the
prosecutor is confident early on that
the target has committed a serious crime
there's always a temptation to will a
prosecution
a charge into existence
even when the facts the law or the
fair-handed administration of justice do
not support
bringing the charge this risk is
inevitable and cannot be avoided simply
by
hiring as prosecutors only moral
people with righteous motivations
i am reminded of a passage by c s lewis
it may be better to live under robber
barons
than under omnipotent moral busybodies
the robber baron's cruelty may sometimes
sleep
his cupidity may at some point be
satiated
but those who torment us for our own
good
will torment us without end for they
do so with the approval of their own
conscience
they may be more likely to go to heaven
i don't know but
at the same time likelier to make hell
on earth
there's yet another reason for having
layers of supervision
individual prosecutors can sometimes
become head hunters
it's all too often they're consumed with
taking
down their target subjecting their
decisions to review by detached
supervisors ensure
the involvement of dispassionate
decision makers
this was of course the central problem
with the independent council statute
that justice scalia criticized in
morrison versus olson creating an
unaccountable head hunter
was not some unfortunate byproduct of
that statute it was the stated purpose
of the statute
that was what justice scalia meant by
his famous line
this wolf comes as a wolf
as we went as he went on to explain
quote how frightening it must be
to have your own independent counsel and
staff appointed
with nothing else to do but to
investigate
you into until
investigation is no longer worthwhile
with whether it is worthwhile not
depending upon
what such judgments usually
hinge on competing responsibilities
and to have that counsel and staff
decide with no basis for comparison
whether what you have done is bad enough
willful enough and provable
enough to warrant an indictment
how admirable the constitutional system
that provides the means to avoid
such a distortion and how unfortunate
the judicial decision that has permitted
it
now
that was a problem that took care of
itself it was
a statute that democrats applauded until
it applied to bill clinton
and then they did we did away with it in
h.w
bush's administration took the heat
castigated by all the media for killing
the independent council statute
and then during the transition bernie
nussbaum who lasted about
two seconds as he as a white house
counsel
a fancy new york lawyer came down and he
was
part of the transition and he came in
and he said you have any advice this was
while i was my last days as attorney
general
and i said well i said um
i think you should allow the independent
council to die its natural death here
we took the heat for it we did we did
the uh what was had it to be done
don't resuscitate it as a republican
nothing would please me more but as an
american
it's a bad statute and he said well we
are committed to the most
moral and ethical administration and
history and we're gonna we are going to
uh reenact it so they did and the rest
is history
by the way if you want a little kick
go to c-span i think they took my name
off of it
but if you put in you know civil lib
civiletti
special you know independent council
statute
nadler you'll see a hearing from like
1995 or 6 or whenever the
white water thing was going on with ben
civility democrat bill barr
republican nadler leading the committee
about how
terrible the independent council statute
was
and how terrible stock ken starr
was and it's a great actually you should
you know if you have time look at it
because you know all the arguments
that we're making here today nowadays
were laid out
of course the role of the players was he
said mr barr i admire you you are very
consistent on this question
so uh anyway uh
it's it's it's fun to watch he
anyway
so anyway
now i said headhunters and that's
because as jackson said
if the prosecutor is obliged to choose
his cases
it follows that he can choose his
defendants therein is the most
dangerous power of the prosecutor that
he will pick people that he thinks he
should get rather than pick the cases
that need to be prosecuted
any erosion and prosecutorial detachment
is extraordinarily perilous
for as he said it is in this realm
in which the prosecutor picks some
person
whom he dislikes or desires to embarrass
or selects some group
of unpopular persons and then looks for
an offense
that the greatest danger of abuse of
prosecuting power lies
it is here that law enforcement becomes
personal and the real crime
becomes that of being unpopular with a
predominant or governing group
being attached to the wrong political
views
or being personally obnoxious to
or in any way the to the prosecutor
himself
and that's what we frequently say i'd
like to be able to stand here and say we
don't see head hunting in the department
of justice and that would not be
truthful
i see it every day and it's a temptation
that the power of prosecution is a heady
power
and it is a temptation sometimes to go
after
people rather than crimes
and we see that every night
you know this country is in serious
problems
with all the problems with real problems
we face in international affairs and
domestically
when most of our news coverage or what
passes for
news coverage are you know bloviating
talking
heads discussing whether some action in
washington
some action taken by an official
constitutes some
esoteric crime and you know looking
through statute books
can we could we you know say that this
is a crime
because disagreement no longer is enough
political disagreement and political
debate now you have to call your
adversary a criminal
and instead of beating them politically
you try to put them in jail so we're
becoming sort of like an eastern
european country
where if you're if you're not in power
you're in jail or you're a member of the
press
so
now one of the areas that i think
there's a problem is
the way we interpret statutes these days
and we have to recalibrate that if we're
ever going to
restore the rule of law clarity
in the law is indispensable
to the rule of law and
if a law is malleable
then it can be applied differently in
different cases
and that is the breakdown
of law now one of the most irritating
developments over the last 50 60 years
is equity driving law
out of the marketplace
if you go and read supreme court
decisions
the supreme court thinks it's being also
and this has been as i say going on for
decades instead of articulating
a law a rule
they say it's the totality of
circumstances
and it's equity what if you know what
was the conscience of the
of the fifth vote on the supreme court
or
and you know they can't articulate the
rule but it's that very discipline
of being able to universalize the
principle that you're applying in a case
that ensures the rule of law and that
ensures that the person is being treated
fairly and it is that process of
universalizing it
that says i'm only going to apply to
this person
what i'm willing to do to every other
similarly situated person and be able to
articulate
the rule and we've completely lost that
in our law and that's why lawyers
are so infuriating beyond their normal
uh you know irritating nature which is
they can't tell the client what the law
is
you know well you could go this way it
could go that way
and that's because their law has broken
down and it's broken down because the
justices don't feel they have to go
through that discipline anymore
the nature of judicial power is being
debased
and we don't you know you can't
equity has its uses and its place but it
can't be constitutional law and these
are some of the points that
are similar to made by justice scalia in
his article about
the rule of law being the law of rules
now in recent years the department of
justice has sometimes acted like a trade
association for prosecutors
more like that than than the
administrator of a fair system of
justice based on clear and sensible
rules
in case after case we've advanced and
defended hyper-aggressive
extensions of the criminal law this is
wrong
and we have to stop doing it now
i couldn't believe it you know i'd get
in and
i'd see some statute and
people would say well how are we going
to interpret this you know interpret the
statute
this court over here said this should be
limited to such and such are we going to
acquiesce in that and adopt that as our
interpretation
and normally the answer you would get in
the department of justice is well
that sort of ties us down of course
that's the whole point
of law
that sort of ties us down you know we
want you know
we want our prosecutors have the
broadest possible discretion
so we can't buy into that
let's leave it loosey-goosey and uh
i said well no i mean uh we have to say
what the law is
and that decision was a good
interpretation of the law
and it should be adopted the fact that
it
hems us in and we can't just use this
law you know as a utility knife
is a good thing but
that's not the perspective generally and
institutionally recently in the
department of justice
um we should want a fair system with
clear rules that people can understand
it does not serve the ends of justice to
advocate for fuzzy and manipulable
criminal prohibitions and maximize the
options of the prosecutors
preventing that sort of pro-prosecutor
uncertainty
is what the ancient rule of leninity is
all about
i'm sure you know what that is which is
if there's vagueness in a law
you you interpret it in the most lenient
way possible from the standpoint of the
defendant
and that rule should like likewise
inform
what we do at the department of justice
when we think about the substance of the
criminal
law advocating for clear and defined
prohibitions
will sometimes mean that we cannot bring
charges against someone whom we believed
is engaged in bad
conduct but that is what it means to be
a government
of laws and not men we cannot let our
desire
to get bad people turn into the
functional equivalent of the
mad emperor caligula who inscribed
criminal laws in tiny script
atop the atop a tall pillar where no one
could read it
to be clear what i'm describing is not
the al capone situation
where you have someone who has committed
multiple crimes and you decide to
prosecute that person for only the
clearest violation
that carries a sufficient penalty i am
talking about taking vague statutory
language
and then applying it to criminal a
criminal target in a novel way
that is at minimum hardly clear
from the statutory text this is
inherently
unfair because criminal prosecutions are
backward looking
we charge people with crimes based on
past conduct
if it was unknown or unclear that the
conduct was illegal when the person
engaged in it that raises real questions
about whether it is fair to prosecute
the person criminally for it
examples of the department defending
these sorts of extreme positions are
unfortunately numerous
as are the rejections of those arguments
by the supreme court
these include arguments as varied as the
departments insisting
that a philadelphia woman violated the
chemical weapons convention
implementation act
implementing the convention on the
prohibition of the development
production
stockpiling and use of chemical weapons
she did this by putting chemicals on her
neighbor's doorknob
as part of an acrimonious love triangle
involving the woman's husband
the court unanimously rejected that
argument in bond versus united states
or they argued that a fisherman violated
the anti-shredding provisions
of the sarbanes-oxley law when he threw
undersized grouper over the side of his
boat
which the supreme court rejected in
yates versus the united states
or more recently arguing that aids to
the governor
of new jersey fraudulently quote
obtained property from the government
when they realigned the lanes on the
george washington bridge to create a
traffic jam
which the supreme court unanimously
rejected in kelly
versus the united states
there are many other examples in fact
you know it's interesting when people
say that the trump administration is
lawless and i usually scratching my head
saying you know we
we litigate all our stuff we win a lot
of it do we go through the process you
know what
what exactly is lawless about it
the fact is that the obama
administration had the worst
record in the supreme court of any
recent administration
losing cases and you know our
administration
so far has been doing you know above
average in terms of uh winning in the
supreme court
so you know
i wouldn't say we were lawless
but again the obama administration
you know had some of the people who were
in mueller's office writing their briefs
in the supreme court so
maybe that explains something
yeah very aggressive positions very you
know sort of uh
uh aggressive and you know we're gonna
we're gonna prosecute these people and
so forth and then
you know they're not growing so much
after they get whopped in the supreme
court
anyway taking a capacious approach to
criminal law is not only unfair to the
criminal
and bad for the department it's
corrosive of our political system
if criminal statutes are endlessly
manipulable and everything becomes a
potential crime
rather than watch policy experts debate
the merits and demerits of a particular
policy choice we are treated
i anticipated this in my earlier
statement we you know these
pundits speculating about whether things
can be prosecuted
this criminalization of politics is not
healthy
the criminal law is supposed to be
reserved for the most egregious
misconduct
conduct so bad that our society has
decided it requires serious punishment
up to and including being locked away
these tools are not built
to resolve political disputes and it
would be a bad
development for us to go the way
of these third world countries where
political parties routinely
prosecute their opponents for various
ill-defined
crimes against the state this is not the
stuff of a mature
democracy we bet this
culture of criminalization when we are
not disciplined about
what charges we will bring what legal
theories
we will adopt rather than root out
true crimes while leaving ethically
dubious conduct to the voters our
prosecutors have all too often inserted
themselves into the political process
based on the flimsiest of legal theories
we have seen this time and time again
with prosecutors bringing
ill-conceived to charges against
prominent political figures
or launching debilitating investigations
that thrust the department of justice
into the middle of the political process
and preempt the ability of the people to
decide
this criminalization of politics will
only worsen until we change the culture
of concocting new legal theories to
criminalize
all manner of questionable conduct smart
ambitious lawyers
have sought to amass glory by
prosecuting prominent
public figures since the roman republic
it is utterly unsurprising
that prosecutors continue continue to do
so today
to the extent the justice department
leaders will permit it
and as long as i'm attorney general
we're not going to permit it
in short it is important for prosecutors
at the department of justice to
understand
that their mission above all above all
others
is to do justice and that means
following the letter of the law
and the spirit of fairness sometimes
that will mean investing months or years
in an investigation and then concluding
it is without
criminal charges our job
is to be just as dogged in preventing
injustice
as we are in pursuing wrongdoing
on this score as in many justice jackson
said it best and i'll
close with his words the qualities of a
good prosecutor
are as elusive and as impossible to
define as
those which mark a gentleman and those
who need to be told
would not understand it anyway
a sensitiveness to fair play and
sportsmanship is perhaps the best
protection against the abuse of power
and the citizens safety lies in the
prosecutor
who tempers zeal with human kindness
who seeks truth and not victims
who serves the law and not factional
purposes
and who above all approaches his task
with humility thank you
thank you
thank you
awesome is this so is this on yeah
again i'm sorry for those prepared
remarks
i like these things a lot better you
know but
so thank you general that was
spectacular
also profound i think so i have the
first question
i've got a few from the audience and the
minute
your duties require you to go home and
rest you may do so
of course even though he just said that
he wouldn't prosecute me just because
he's mad at me
um so partly what you just said was a
a process of a transfer of authority
from
elected people to civil servants
do you see that going on in other parts
of the government
you know of course but this is the game
at the department of justice
you know how it's been used as a
political football basically the
when when the left controls the
executive branch
uh then no one says anything about
the supervision of the lawyers in the
department of justice
being by the political officials but
when the republicans win or
conservatives
are in charge of the department of
justice then all we hear
day in and day out is the you know
that people we should just stand back
and let the career
people run the department of justice
and you know don't get me wrong i mean
a lot of my family are career people in
the department of justice i love the
department of justice i love the people
in the department of justice
but as i say the legitimacy in our
system comes from
political supervision and political
accountability
should the supreme court have the
exclusive power to interpret the
constitution
yes
so this is not my question but i'll
sharpen it so the president
takes an oath to help me say that
uh i think
president jackson was correct that each
branch has in the first instance the
responsibility to
interpret the constitution and what they
think
the constitution means and so if an exec
if the president believes that he has
the power to do something under the
constitution
he should be able to to exercise that
power and if
the court disagrees and orders him not
to then
he's lost the case
that's what i thought uh what's your
favorite song
to play on the bagpipes
i don't know who it is too many there
are too many songs there are it's not
songs they're called
tunes t-u-n-e-s scotland the brave
well that's a very common one that's the
one i that you see on the video
playing scotland the brave but
i uh i miss playing the bagpipes
uh once when i was attorney general last
time
you know scalia called the chambers and
said
to my assistant uh do you think uh the
attorney general would like to take a
you know quick walk with me around the
mall
and i said ask justice scalia
whether he realizes it's a federal
offense to threaten the life of a
federal official i say the same thing
about playing the bagpipes these days
people ask me to play the bagpipes i say
you know it's an offense a threat in the
life
emergency vehicles standing by
i think a definition of a gentleman is
somebody who knows how to play the
bagpipes and does not
no i disagree with that
played since i was eight years old and
you know my parents being academicians
and growing up on the upper west side
and bella abzug's district in new york
we lived in columbia university housing
which was great housing
overlooking the hudson river and stuff
but
uh they want you know they said billy
it's time that you learn an instrument
violin piano i said bagpipes
somebody wonders if ballot harvesting is
uh
constitutional and also how do we go
about in this day and age guaranteeing
the
propriety of our elections
well i'm not i you know i know because
i'm attorney general i was once head of
the office of legal counsel which is
sort of a
legal beagle office i can't off the top
of my head give you authoritative
answers on some of these questions i
will just say generally i'm very
concerned
let me draw a distinction between what
may pass buster under some recent case
law of the supreme court and what really
is
in accord with the constitutional scheme
and the basic
principles and sometimes you have to go
back to basic principles
to understand what some of the some of
you know the provisions of the
constitution should mean so as
i've said you know the whole idea of an
election
is to have a single expression
of will by everybody at the same time
based on the same information that's
what an election
is not an election so we have election
day and now we have an election
season and not only that it's a season
that has like uh
extra innings so
it's becoming absurd
decisions made weeks apart are are not
you know the body politic making a sober
decision about the state of affairs
at one time so we're losing the whole
idea of what an election is
um and when when people you know try to
play games like
can you do you have any empirical
evidence uh
that you know mail-in ballots are you
know
i have common sense we haven't had it on
the scale that's being proposed now so i
don't have empirical
other than the fact that we've always
had voting fraud
uh and they're you know there always
will be people who attempt to uh
to do that i don't have empirical
evidence that on this scale
uh you know these problems were
materialized but what i say to people is
why do we vote today the way we do think
about it
why does this why do people show up at
one place where they have a list of
people who are eligible to vote
you set you show who you are you go
behind a
curtain why do you go behind a curtain a
secret ballot
no one else is allowed there why is that
a rule
coercion undue influence why a secret
ballot many reasons you can't sell or
buy
votes easily if there's a secret ballot
you you don't succumb as much to to undo
influence or pressure
that is all blown away the lessons
of the english system before us and the
american system
and how the vote evolved and how we
tried to perfect it
and protect its integrity
for all this time are just swept away
by mail-in voting where you don't have
an anonymity
your name is connected to that vote and
you open the floodgates to coercion and
so
i don't think harvesting should be
permitted personally
some states have passed down under the
constitution the law set the
state set the rules they're permitting
harvesting of ballots but
it's a potential abuse
and
uh i go back to your main argument and
that is
uh the authority of the attorney general
comes through the president from the
people
and so do you sense a uh growing spirit
of managing the people
managing how they vote managing what
they can do for by the government
well i think it raises the fundamental
question
which is this that our constitution was
meant
for a discerning informed
virtuous people and
you have to raise the question of
whether we still have that
in our country but we certainly have
forces that are attempting to cultivate
uh a dependent people and it's you know
it's the same old game it's bred
what's our bread and circuses today it's
all distraction
you know as as uh pascal said it's all
about distracting people from anything
that's important and principle and
what's happening
that's why so many people don't pay
attention they're distracted they're
distracted by
you know all the stimulation of their
senses that go on
and it's becoming and that goes part and
parcel with creating dependence
so you have more and more people that
just don't care
you know i was mortif you know you you
i saw it today that most people don't
know what the holocaust
is about in the united states some poll
or something
i couldn't believe it now
i thought they tossed taught holocausts
or or concentration camps very well in
school because when i was giving a
memorial day speech one year i did some
research
and most high school students if you ask
them
uh what do you know about world war ii
well first they don't know who fought
in world war ii who the united states
was fighting
but then they say what they know about
world war ii is about the concentration
camps
and that we use nuclear weapons against
japan
those are the two things i said oh
constantly at least you learned about
the concentration camps
yes the internment of the japanese
yeah you should visit some high schools
today
if mueller's team mueller's dream
whatever you call it
destroyed information who's responsible
and what
i think they're talking about wiping
phones who's responsible
what what what consequences can there be
well i don't want to get into that
particular thing the
you know the appropriate people in the
department are taking a look at that and
we'll see
we'll see where that goes
what are the constitutional hurdles for
forbidding a church from meeting
during covet 19
what are the constitutional hurdles too
forbidding
what in other words okay so you know
there's a
you know it's this um the rule right now
is articulated by the supreme court
some people might disagree with it but
uh in the sense that it doesn't go far
enough in protecting religion but
the current standard is that you cannot
you you can place restrictions on
religion the exercise of religion
as long as you don't discriminate
against religion
and apply the same restrictions on
everybody else
that is similarly situated so you can't
allow people to
go to theaters and get together in
commercial establishments or other kinds
of activities and then prohibit
churches from doing it and
you know some of the states were going
that far
so that's the basic hurdle you have to
get over now
i know you're from michigan and
therefore you're particularly sensitive
to the
caprice of governor's regulations
i i very amused because
the press gets all huffy and puffy
about you know bill barr believes in
strong executive power
ooh you know he's a he's a fascist or
something like that
and yet they said which
you know i won't even respond to but
they couldn't be happier with governor
that governors are exercising
kind of power are they exercising
executive power
in many states there are no statutes
that uh
you know or the legislatures bowed out
of the picture
right and uh just letting the governors
do do what they want to do now
uh what i've said is yes there is
executive power by its very nature does
come
and should fill the void right at the
beginning of any crisis like this and
some crises like war
uh you you do need a strong
component of executive leadership but
once the emergency nature of it starts
to abate the legislature should give a
little bit more guidance like yeah you
can do this for 30 years
30 days and then come back to us and you
know if you don't like what we're doing
you're doing you know we'll
exercise a little more control over it
but there has been very little of that
and most of the governors do what
bureaucrats always do which is they act
you know they defy common sense and a
lot of what they do
um and uh
you know they they enjoy you know they
they uh
treat free citizens as babies that
you know can't take responsibility for
themselves and others
so i was saying oh lord you know we have
to give business people
an opportunity tell them what the rules
are you know the
masks which rule of masks do you have
this month
and uh you know tell us what to tell the
business people what the rules are
and then let them try to adapt their
business to that and and you'll have
ingenuity and people will
at least have the freedom to try to earn
a living
but but but you know putting a national
lockdown
stay-at-home orders is like house arrest
it's not
it's the it's you know other than
slavery which was a different kind of
restraint
this is the greatest intrusion on civil
liberties in american history
and so you know i do disagree with the
supreme
we supported this case
you know we we did get a lot of the
churches uh the states to
to ease up on the churches and and you
know we'd write letters to the governors
and the gov
governors would comply but this case
my view was it doesn't take a rocket
scientist to realize that an artificial
cap of 10
doesn't make any sense when you're
talking about saint patrick's cathedral
compared to a small country church and
so
one of the rules under the constitution
is you have to sort of calibrate
whatever burden
you're going to place on religion you're
going to have to take account of the
circumstances and make it as narrow as
possible
to achieve your end and so
we said you know how about of just a
percentage of the fire marshal occupancy
standard
you know and the supreme court
5-4 vote wouldn't uh wouldn't go along
with that because they wanted to say
that
well you have to give a lot of latitude
to governors in these crisis and i agree
you should give a lot of latitude but
uh you know
we we have epidemics and pandemics this
is a very serious one a grave one
but uh they they come and and you know
just because something is a medical
crisis it doesn't give a complete blank
check
to to executive rule
that leads me to wonder so
i read that there have been north of 75
000 suicides
during the shutdown and what mechanism
is there or should there be in the
government to take care of all these
ancillary facts effects
here's my problem which is i have great
respect for the medical profession
the scariest day in a lawyer's life is
when he realizes the medical profession
is really pretty much the same as the
legal profession
okay they're human beings they put their
pants
on you know one leg at a time they're
right sometimes they're wrong other
times
they disagree with each other there's
some good doctors there's some
bad doctors but just like lawyers
doctors
some will will they're specialists
they will they will view a broad social
problem
an issue through a set of blinders
in a sense so you know your doctor might
say to you
bill if you want to live 20 years longer
you know you should just
do this this this this and this and he
might be right
but i don't want to pay those costs to
live 20 years
longer i'd rather take my chances now i
understand their externalities here and
you you you know you can't
threaten other people's life but the
point is that
you know you have to balance that
against a lot of other factors and the
point you
made is exactly what was not done but
was self-evident
anyone who had the power of logic
which is yes doctor you might be right
but just think of all the collateral
consequences and the costs
of that and that is not
science okay
it is the generalist and the people and
the representatives of
the entire community that should be
making these balancing acts
it is not dictated by science so all
this
nonsense about how this is dictated
something is dictated by science is
nonsense
okay so
but so anyway i mean suicides is just
the tip of the iceberg the overdoses are
out of control
they're getting back up again after the
first time
in decades this administration actually
started flattening it out and
bringing it down a little on opioids
going back up again
and now with methamphetamine cheap
methamphetamine now swamping the country
and forms of opioid that are extremely
deadly fentanyl synthetic opioids
we now have the overdose deaths going up
we have domestic violence getting out of
control
i'm sure that the these uh
shutting down of the economy and and
telling everyone to stay in their house
that's contributed to violent crime
going up in many of our cities
so when you look at the interruption of
education especially for
disadvantaged children in the inner city
is devastating
these costs are massive
and you know it's the how you balance
these things is not dictate you know i'm
sorry a person in the
white coat is not the grand seer
who who can come up with the right
decision for society
a free people makes its decision through
its elected representatives
this is from a senior at the hillsdale
academy
they're very nerdy down there what is
the relationship between the rule of law
and economic prosperity
uh one is the foundation of the other
the rule of law is the foundation of
economic process
is the rule of law uh
uh is uh the foundation of civilization
including economic prosperity and that's
why
these so-called black lives matter
people
now that as a proposition who can
quarrel with the proposition black lives
matter but
they're not interested in black lives
they're interested in they're interested
in
props a small number of blacks who were
killed by police during
conflict with police usually less than a
dozen a year
who they can use as props to achieve a
much broader political agenda
but i view the question of black lives
as not only
keeping people alive but also
having prosperity and flourishing in
their communities
and most uh
deaths in this in in in the inner city
of young black males below the age of 44
the leading cause of death is
being shot by another black person
and that's crime and
all these great you know the left likes
to talk about dealing with the root
causes
but all their solutions depend on
peaceful streets at the end of the day
you know education after after-school
activities
all this stuff depends on
peace if your school is run by a gang
it's not going to get you anywhere and
so as i say the foundation of all human
progress
is the rule of law
you've enjoyed excellent treatment by
the media
and certainly they are relative
certainly they are attentive
do you think you know for example
newspapers in the 19th century in the
18th century were often
founded with party names in them
something federalist in the
you know arizona republican is the press
more partisan now
what what what do you make of it is it
different in kind from what we've had in
the past well i'm not
no i mean uh well
they're more ignorant than we've had in
the past
but you know you you go back
the press has gone i'm not an expert on
the history of the press
but uh yes
when you used to have when de
tocqueville
wrote you used to have small towns
that today couldn't support one
newspaper supporting 10 12
15 newspapers and yes they were
factional and they were political and
then
you know to the extent there was a
national press there wasn't much of one
but at the extent there was it was
sometimes rapidly partisan and they were
quite harsh
and so forth uh
and then they but then more recently
they've gone through they went through
this long period where they were
objective it was a profession journalism
and they were a profession and they held
themselves out to be
objective and they were journalists and
they were you know trying to tell the
truth
uh or that's what they told us and that
has
gone by the boards long time ago
as i've said you know as soon as they
started working the first time i heard
the word narrative
there was like some period of time a few
years ago where the word narrative just
started popping up
everywhere with a narrative and a
narrative and that i said
that's it we've had it because the whole
words suggest there's no objective truth
that it's everyone's perception of the
truth you have your narrative
you have your narrative who's to say
whose narrative is correct
and so there's been they don't care that
they're not telling the truth because
they don't believe
truth is a meaningful concept it's about
the pursuit of power
and so
i'd be more tolerant of it if they were
informed
people but they're not i
you know in the old days even you know
the great liberal journalists
were very educated erudite people
one last uh
you know actually so the freedom of the
press
is something i have it's something you
have is something we all have
because it was written at a time when
you had pamphleteers and anyone could
get their views out
in some ways we're going back to that
with the internet which has many very
bad
uh effects but the fact of the matter is
that this idea that the media
someone who puts on a press thing
somehow has
more rights than somebody else to
freedom of speech
or that what they write or put out is
somehow
legitimate journalism and what you write
is
is not is nonsense
so one last youtube and google are
private companies big private companies
and they have an announced policy that
they will not permit anything on their
platform that calls into question
the world health organization guidelines
and so last week a three-month-old
article by scott
atlas who's recently described disgraced
himself by going to work
in the white house was taken down
and that means that youtube and google
made a decision that his
you know of course we now know he's not
really a scientist because
because somebody see it and said he
wasn't but what about that
what is is that constitutional does the
degree of control collected in those
companies
make them subject to some law than other
than just doing what they want
well you know i think it's
constitutional in the sense that
as long as it's not state action
involved because private people
you know have the have the ability to do
that
what you really have to ask yourself is
the market power they have the power
that they've attained over time in the
market and whether
you know their questions you know
whether whether we can inject more
competition
and more diversity into the market you
know
the tocqueville famously talked about
the real risk of the of the united
states and democracy generally was
slipping into soft despotism
the kind of world we see about us now
and he said he thought the two things
that could save the united states from
this
was religion and
the freedom of the press but what he
said about the freedom of the press was
it's it's very diversity
it wasn't he had a very low opinion of
the press the tocqueville
he didn't think that the freedom of the
press would would save the united states
because
you know these guardians of the truth
and expose are out there on the front
line protecting our liberties far
from it but what he said was the sheer
diversity
because when you get into a position
where there's one person
you know one force or power lashing the
multitude
you get the
militant majority the galvanized
majority which was the great threat
and as you know under framers thought
that there were different ways they were
preventing you know the coalescence
of these different factions and uh
nowadays it's it's hard to imagine a
more concentrated situation where people
are all
fed the same crap and
you can galvanize a majority like that
in this country
at least a numeric majority i love it
when fox news
shows all the talking points that
every single station uses they all the
exact
and i wouldn't be surprised like they
have a conference call at the beginning
every day okay what's the message of the
day and they use exactly the same
language
that's bad now those are a lot of that
is public airwaves i think we have to
take a look at that
myself but uh
you know it's the same thing with with
virtually all media
and now on the on the internet you have
these vast
concentrations of power that
are bigger and more powerful than
virtually every nation in the world with
the exception of a handful
and you know they think that they
are the arbiters of truth and and
control the message that people get
anyway so i think we must thank the
attorney general
thank you thanks
you're a blessing